وبحسب ما ورد كان أربعة مواطنين روس على الأقل من
بين القتلى على يد حماس
في إسرائيل، لكن الرئيس الروسي
اختار حتى الآن عدم إدانة حماس بسبب
الهجوم. ويقول الكرملين إن فلاديمير
بوتين يشعر بالقلق إزاء عدد
الضحايا المدنيين لكنه
يلوم سياستنا إلى حد كبير على ما يحدث.  ما يحدث
في الشرق الأوسط، فريد بين من CNN لديه
تقريرنا وتحذير من أن بعض
مقاطع الفيديو
مزعجة
بعد ذبح مئات الإسرائيليين على يد
حماس بالقرب من غزة، وإدانة
التعازي وتدفق التعازي
من جميع أنحاء العالم ولكن ليس من
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الآن في
أول ظهور له  تعليقات بدلاً من التعاطف، ينتقد بوتين
الولايات المتحدة، وهذا مثال واضح على
فشل سياسة الولايات المتحدة في
الشرق الأوسط التي حاولت
احتكار أي تسوية بين
الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين،
وتتبع قناة الكرملين التلفزيونية التي تسيطر عليها حذوها،
وتسخر من كل من أمريكا وإسرائيل
بزعم أنهما تم القبض عليهما.  حراسة من
هجوم حماس، الموساد
والاستخبارات المضادة الشهيرة، وكذلك الولايات المتحدة
ووكالة المخابرات المركزية التابعة لها، نامت خلال
غزو حماس، إنه أكبر
فشل إسرائيلي في الأمن منذ عام
1973. روسيا متحالفة منذ فترة طويلة مع
أقوى خصوم إسرائيل وأهم
داعمي حماس الذين يقصفون
المتمردين السوريين دعماً لحماس.  مقاتلون موالون لإيران
يقاتلون إلى جانب
الرئيس السوري بشار الأسد خلال
الحرب الأهلية السورية لكن روسيا حافظت أيضًا على
علاقات قوية وترتيبات أمنية مع
إسرائيل. التقى بوتين برئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو في
مناسبات عديدة نحن لا نقلل من
أهمية أه إجراءات ذلك
سيضمن أه أمنًا قويًا جدًا لدولة
إسرائيل ولكن منذ أن شن بوتين
حربه الشاملة ضد أوكرانيا
أصبح تان حليفًا رئيسيًا لموسو على
حساب إسرائيل حيث يعزز العلاقات الاقتصادية والعسكرية
مع إيران بينما يزود تان
الجيش الروسي بالعشرات من طائرات الشاهد بدون طيار
اعتاد الروس على ضرب
المدن والبنية التحتية الأوكرانية،
تقول KV إنه على الرغم من أن تان ينفي ذلك، فإن
الرئيس الأوكراني فلاديمير زينسكي يدعي أن
ولاء موسكو في الشرق الأوسط
قد تحول نحو
CRI، نرى كيف تتفاخر الدعاية الروسية،
ونشهد كيف
يقدم حلفاء موسكو الإيرانيون الدعم علنًا لأولئك الذين
هاجموا.  نفى الكرملين إسرائيل الآن مزاعم
فلاديمير زينسكي
بأنها تحاول تأجيج
الوضع بين الإسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين، لكن
الحاخام الأكبر السابق لموسكو الذي فر بالطبع من ذلك
البلد بعد أسبوعين من
الغزو الكامل لأوكرانيا قال إنه
يعتقد ذلك  يعد عدم إظهار
الدعم الروسي لإسرائيل
علامة مشؤومة على تدهور العلاقات
بين تلك الدول. فريد هين سي إن إن
كييف